[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hello good morning and welcome to safety
Ridge on Sunday now I'm not sure if you
caught Eurovision last night Liverpool
did a great job in hosting but the rest
of the continent didn't really think
much of the UK entry which finished
second last what the government has once
again got a big Europe problem here at
home too rowing back on plans to get rid
of all EU laws has riled up the
conservative rights and we'll hear from
one of the most prominent on the show
this morning it feels like this weekend
is when we're truly starting to see The
Fallout of those disastrous local
election results but are we going to see
a change of direction from Rishi
silacing us this morning on the program
we are going to be hearing in just a
moment from the energy security and that
zero secretary Grant shafts for labor
we'll talk to the shadow business
secretary Jonathan Reynolds and with
conservatives on the right voicing their
concerns about the direction of travel
we'll speak to the former business
secretary that it is Jacob Reese morgue
we'll also talk live to the mayor of
Greater Manchester who is Andy Burnham
and someone who is no stranger should we
say to the cotton Trust of Politics the
former Downing Street director of
communications Alistair Campbell and his
daughter to keep him in check the
Comedian Chris Campbell that would be
worth a watch
[Music]
well let's start this morning with the
government just a few moments ago I
spoke to the energy security and net
Syria secretary squash apps
how would you describe the mood in the
concept of party now so look of course
we have a great opportunity because we
we know that we're buzzing with ideas
we've got uh a lot of energy uh to get
things done still uh but uh of course
there are many many challenges facing
the country and by the way they'll be
facing whoever whomever was in power at
this point in time but the reason I say
I think we've got opportunities now is
that uh we're the party who you know has
managed to get unemployment very low
people in work and despite the very very
tough times we've looked after people
through the latest crisis which is the
Ukraine war by for example paying around
half of people's energy bills this
winter so I think we've got the ideas
but also the Practical Solutions uh not
to say there aren't many challenges
along the way and that's the pitch
but what's the mood like well look uh
I think that uh the mood is one of
Steely determination well I think we
think that we
um know that there's a job to do that we
are on the side of the British people
and you know whether that is getting
inflation halved or growing the economy
uh or reducing debt dealing with the NHS
waiting list okay and the rest of it
okay stopping the boats we're the ones
who are on the side of the public Steely
determination
um you've got these two mysterious
conferences that are sprung up right the
conservative Democratic organization in
Bournemouth yesterday the national
conservatism conference in London
tomorrow as far as I can tell the sole
purpose seems to be to give conserve to
MPS a platform to give Rishi sinaka
kicking I look I I just think a great
party like the conservative party who
sort of renews itself by buzzing with NG
and ideas always welcomes the idea that
people are thinking through the problem
games that come ahead when I was
reselected as the candidate the MP for
the candidate for well in Hatfield my
own constituency my own local
Association my own members wanted to
know what both what my ideas were and
tell them about their own and so it's
quite right for MPS to be able to meet
discuss ideas and then play those into
what will be a wider manifest it feels
like more than just discussing ideas
more than Steely determination doesn't
it look pretty Patel has said where
she's like Risk being responsible for
the managed decline of the conservative
party after the losses in the local
elections Nadine Dory said you'd had an
astonishing political tumble and you're
going backwards are they right well look
I I simply don't agree if you look at
any party after uh time in office if you
compared us with for example where Blair
and brown were through there period we
still have fun and went on to lose
the point is we still have far more
counselors in place than they would have
done during the same point of the
Electoral cycle so this idea that
there's something written in the stars
that somehow we cannot come back and win
win from our particular position at the
moment completely and fundamentally
disagree with and as I say the fact that
our MPS are still thinking of ideas
buzzing with energy uh buzzing with new
ideas that's a good thing not a bad
thing I guess listening to you
this feels like what some of these MPS
are worried about you just had a
thousand over a thousand Council seat
losses right labor are on course to win
the next election all of the polling
says that and yet what you're hearing
from the top team is fingers and ears
we're just going to keep on delivering
no that's not what I think at all I mean
look first of all we've gone through an
enormous Global pandemic and that's been
expensive and then we've gone through
the Warren uh Ukraine uh and that's what
I mean
if I may you know this is what I kind of
mean because I've been hearing these
excuses from the conservative party for
you know the last year now on interviews
it feels like there should be a change
in tone and message after seeing Rishi
sunx first tested the Electoral box and
no no and this is where I think this is
where this is I think fundamentally
wrong the test was not as as you suggest
Rishi sunax first test at The Ballot Box
in that sense it was probably people
with the first opportunity to talk about
what was a fairly difficult period last
summer that people will remember and
this is the first time people have been
asked to go to The Ballot Box and I know
talking to my constituents many of them
have said look I just want to make the
point that I was not happy with what
happened last summer
but uh well we have these changes of
um of leadership and it's been very well
documented as as you know but actually
people realize this country has gone
through some pretty difficult times and
of course we won't have got everything
right but we have managed to steer the
country through it roll out vaccines or
provide up to half of people's the
typical uh Energy bill this this winter
wrapped our arms around and tried to
help people and uh that isn't going to
be easy to do but Rishi sunak actually
has stabilized the party I mean I invite
you to imagine all people who think that
to imagine what it might have been like
four or five six months ago if the
elections are being held there so
management decline rather than unmanaged
decline I just fundamentally disagree
and by the way I think if you are sort
of falling into or sharing the idea that
it's completely inevitable that sakir
starmer who one day to the next simply
doesn't even know what he believes in
but he'll always go where he thinks uh
it's convenient to go look at the things
he stood on to become leader of the
opposition which was a radical left
platform look at the things he's saying
uh now he'll say whatever left part of
this platform well of course he he tried
to appeal to Ascension but generally
what was what was the radical part of
this platform listed on well for example
a policy example for example he stood on
10 different pledges many of which was
Radical left if you let me answer the
question many of which carried on
supporting uh some of the policies that
uh before him uh corbyn had in place
this is a man but what's the radical
left well let me talk to the agenda this
is a man who sat in the Corbin Shadow
cabinet whilst
while and defended essentially therefore
corbins and cemeters he defended
Corbin's attacks on businesses and he
carried on playing not on and semitism
but in other areas to that agenda in his
10-point plan that got him elected then
dumps it and says no no uh I'm ready now
to to lead the country and again you
know today in in the newspapers we
learned that he has a plan uh to change
the electoral system uh to do to go
further than was the case for example
even when we were in the EU so he's
supposed to want to re-negotiate brexit
again
just talk about that uh actually because
that is one of the things in the
newspapers today uh kirst armor
apparently uh looking at
um opening up the voting system so the
settled migrants for example EU citizens
who live work pay taxes in the UK could
get the vote along with 16 and 17 year
olds not something useful we don't have
any plans to change the electoral system
and again what he's actually doing to
put that in another to make that clear
he's reopening the brexit settlement
this is a settlement we have made with
EU countries to have reciprocal
arrangements so British citizens can
abroad are able to vote in for example
the local elections say in Spain and the
same here what he plans to do is
actually reopen the brexit settlement so
what else will he reopen the The Windsor
framework the the the the cooperation
agreement with Europe uh this again is
kirst armor doing whatever he thinks is
practical uh to do at that moment in
time or in his personal advantage to at
that point in time it doesn't have
fundamental ideas that he relies on as I
say he stood on one platform is now
shifting to a different okay form and
he'll do the same with reopening brexit
it's clear that you want to talk about
care stomach and can you talk about your
own policies right you're talking about
promising one thing and then doing
another well let's have a look at what
you see next promise to scrap 4000 EU
laws why has he broken his promise well
those laws are being scrapped uh 2 000
of which over 2 000 of which will be
gone by the end of this year the reality
is as the libraries look for more of
these laws that were uh you know sort of
almost leftover pieces of law more of
being discovered in the archives as it
were and so there's a practicality of
Simply getting those through but uh you
know just this week
um the the business secretary put down I
think 600 more that will be scrapped
that will be over 2 000 scrapped by the
end of this year and we carry on that
process
um obviously not the fully at the full
pleasure to get all of them off the
statute book by the end of the year I
just want to read you something from
yesterday's times it's also said that
chaps
believe that the proposal to scrap or
reform all EU laws in the UK statute
book by the end of the year it was
entirely doable and the good progress
was being made when he was in charge of
the policy well I should point out this
is now we're now several months on from
when I was uh business section looking
after this process so more of the laws
will have been uncovered because that
was the work that was going on and so
you've got to work with the Practical is
that Source correct though no you've got
to work with what's there no in the time
that you're actually in that post so
brexit ideology meeting reality then
well look I I was never a sort of
brexiteer in so not my ideology but all
I'm saying is uh things have moved on
now uh the current business actually
will quite rightly be looking at the
body of laws there and working out how
best to take them off our statute but
here's the important principle here's
the important principle why does it even
matter well we've left the uh EU we
shouldn't therefore have laws that sort
of hang over and you know continue to
dictate the way that our country
operates people voted to leave I didn't
but lots of people did and so we
shouldn't have that on the statute but I
have every confidence the current
business secretary is looking at the
plethora of these laws that are left
she's going to have more than 2 scrap by
the end of the year she's just announced
another 600 I think she's doing this the
right way okay and there's been let's
talk about immigration shall we because
there's been an awful lot of focus on
small boats that a policy on Rwanda
which is affected exactly zero people so
far
but I just want to have a look at what's
been happening to net migration I think
we can have a look uh now because we
have been seeing record levels of net
migration to the UK you can see they're
absolutely jumping uh recently and there
are reports that this number is set to
rise to even double to a million are you
in control of net migration you've just
completed two issues actually you've I
just want to sort of correct this you've
talked about small boats and then you've
talked about net migration yeah
absolutely these are two different
things the small boats are absolutely
right this is why I wanted to tell
people not so much this is what I'm
saying that immigration debate has been
dominated by small boats when actually I
want to talk about this legal migration
to the UK that is skyrocketing look
first of all understand that 503 000
figures all these larger numbers include
hundreds of thousands of people that you
mean many other people myself personally
I've had three of these people have
lived in my house in these numbers here
in the last year the Ukrainian refugees
and this country has had a big heart
we've opened the the country for
Ukrainian refugees for British Nationals
from Hong Kong take those two groups
alone and it's well over three hundred
thousand of these numbers and then of
course we've had people from Syria uh
and elsewhere so actually I'm rather
proud of our record but I do just
caution against conflating two very
different issues that's of illegal
absolutely immigration criminals I'm
just talking about illegal talking about
legal migration because there are
reports that this number could double
well is that okay I mean maybe it is
maybe you should say we should be
relaxed about no students about we have
we have uh a a migration advisory uh
committee that says look there's a
shortage in this area or that area one
of the advantages now with brexit is we
have control over our own policies so we
can say uh we we want people to help
with the specific sector but as I say
you and you'll remember this a year ago
a huge clamor to ensure that we're
providing Safe Haven to refugees from
Ukraine three of them lived in my house
so many other people brought were very
generous and brought people just to be
into their homes and that's included in
these numbers just to be clear then we
should be relaxed in in your view about
high legal migration numbers even if
they hit a million right well first I
don't think they're going to hit a
million and secondly uh the important
thing is that Britain has control and if
this country says so the question is
should we be relaxed by high levels of
net migration well we we should always
make sure that we only have people come
here uh that our rules and uh our policy
bring here so if we say we are going to
invite people invite people with
grandfather rights from Hong Kong to
come and live here all ukrainians but I
guess we should be relaxed with high
levels well the point is we should we
should um be proud of our record where
it's people that we want here but we
should not allow people to come here
where it is illegal which is why it's
outrageous okay the kirst armor let's
not okay
I will talk to the opposition about it
okay but when you want to please do
mention to them they keep voting I want
to see our bills to stop the small boats
and it's very important
legal migration but you were talking
about illegal migration no I didn't I
said let's not talk about legal
motivation let's talk about legal money
you started off on the boats I started
off I started off on votes to say let's
not talk about the boat I just want to
make sure we are making sure that we are
stopping that problem I would like to
talk to you about strikes if I may uh
Pat Cullen at the Royal College of
Nursing demanding a double-digit pay
rise for her members is that achievable
I I find it this a very curious story
indeed um because Pat gallim just
recently was encouraging her members to
uh settle for the pay rise that was put
on the table uh that would see five
thousand pounds go into the pockets of
this year of a hard-working nurses I
thought this was a great settlement I
thought it's terrific that it had been
uh reached it's frankly rather confusing
and now that having encouraged her
members to accept that deal she seems to
now be coming back and saying the
opposite I guess maybe she's coming back
because her members turned her down so
they kind of thought it was good enough
well uh as I say people will have to
sort of Judge this but five thousand
Pounds into the pockets of nurses more
for people who are a lower paid uh a
good contribution because in that role
um there's 20 employer contribution to
pensions as well
um and I'm all in favor of this I mean I
think our our nurses work incredibly
hard very pleased to see that settlement
reach but I think it's a bit odd for the
union leaders who have said accept this
and then come back and say oh actually
no we now want to reopen something that
she's already accepted once and
encourage her members to accept so
absolutely no two double-digit paywise
then well as I say you've got to balance
that with the rest of the public purse
and there's a very generous offer now on
the table five five grand uh you know
this year would be coming to nurses
um and uh I think that that would be a
great way to get this thing settled
do you take a bit of responsibility
yourself about setting the tone when it
comes to strikes and I'm just asking
because it feels to me like the train
operators were one of the first the rmt
sorry one of the first people to go on
strike when you were transport secretary
you didn't meet them you said don't risk
striking yourselves out of a job don't
pitch yourselves against the public
something the rmt said they thought was
a threat and now of course we have this
entrenched position with many of the
sides in the debate should you have
struck a more consultant well look I
just think with um Railways we'd spent
billions of pounds keeping the railways
going during um covid 40 of the
passengers haven't come back again uh to
the railways as yet
um and uh they're therefore having to be
propped up by huge taxpayer subsidy and
you've got a situation where train
drivers the aslift union for example or
on average paid nearly 60 000 pounds the
offer on the table puts it up to 65 000
pounds I just it's time to get this
thing put to bed
um on another issue if I may our Deputy
political editor at Sam Coates has been
investigating a conservative police and
crime commissioner Steve Turner now he
instigated or triggered two police
investigations into people that he was
his political opponents he was trying to
be a counselor in redcar
should there be an investigation into
what happened well look other than
having just heard about your reports I'm
not over the detail of this I'm not
familiar with the case itself and
obviously the process is to be followed
and I think it's important that those
are properly uh followed in the normal
way and independently I would suggest to
politicians getting involved in it but
it's important I guess to make sure that
local people who have local power in
areas like this should be out of account
in the usual way yeah absolutely
um but as I said I want to sort of not
comment on something that you know there
is a proper process in place for those
kinds of Investigations uh now I can
help but notice the conservatives lost
control of willing to have for Council
the local elections
the majority but
but we'll see I didn't win the seat the
first time I force it I always treat it
as a marginal and I know that people
have a choice how they vote so I'm
always always on top of that the the
council as you say has gone to know
overall control with the conservatives I
along with the largest party but I never
take it for granted never and uh always
work very hard for my constituents as a
result in well in that field okay thank
you very much indeed thanks
pawn shops there speaking for the
government this morning we can get the
view from labor now because yesterday
the leader kirstalmer said his reforms
the party would be like Tony Blair's
famous Clause full moment in 1995 but in
his words on steroids well I can speak
now to the shadow business secretary
Jonathan Reynolds thank you very much
for being with us this morning
um firstly I just want to look at
reports in the newspapers this morning
that Labor's looking at changing the
voting system to allow settled migrants
so people who may be citizens of other
countries but live work pay taxes in the
UK and also 16 and 17 year olds to have
the vote what's the plan
well good morning look the some of the
speculation that's been in the Press
about Labor policy actually relates to
our policy making process it's not our
Manifesto It's not a statement of party
policy but it's how we go about doing
that we've got a process where people
put in their submissions they're
deliberated on their voted upon so this
is not a statement of policy yet but of
course we're always looking at ways to
strengthen our democracy to involve as
many people impossible as that and
there'll be an element of that the form
of how this country operates how power
is shared in the labor Manifesto that's
for sure
do you personally think it would be a
good idea to allow settled migrants and
16 17 year olds to have a vote then
well I think there are Arguments for
expanding the franchise it's not an area
I directly deal with in the shadow
cabinets I'm not going to give a
definitive answer on that but I think we
should always be seeking to involve as
many people as possible in our democracy
that's what strengthens Democratic
politics that's what we need to see
encouraged and I think we haven't seen
enough of that in recent times so it's
something we will look at but some of
the reports as I've got to stress
they're not the fair final plans for the
labor Manifesto this is about the
process by which we achieve that
Manifesto I mean it could be a pretty
big expansion of the franchise if it was
to be a labor policy one that could also
potentially make it easier for labor to
win an election
I don't think any changes to how the
British State Works how democracy Works
should be ever considered through any
kind of party political lens it should
be about what is right for the country
what is the right way to make politics
work better and that will be the only
criteria we would put forward but it
certainly wouldn't be any consideration
a partisan advantage of course never and
thank you
um for giving us a bit of a steer I
guess on the policy at least now
kirstama says his labor party will have
to be Clause 4 on steroids so that of
course is the moment when Tony Blair
rewrote the labor Constitution to ditch
its commitment to nationalization I mean
that's pretty big talk so what is it
specifically that you want to do
well here is laying out the scale of the
challenge and as we saw in the local
elections when I got to polling there
the big questions for people in this
country are are they better off after 13
years of conservative government do they
think any public services work better
after those 13 years and the scale of
the challenge therefore for labor it's
not just turning around an economy that
hasn't functioned very well for 13 years
it's the complete reform and delivery on
public services in a way where they need
the scale of that I don't think has ever
been greater and specifically for me on
the economic side of the shuttle cabinet
that's bringing the kind of modern
industrial strategy we see in other
countries we see many parts of our
company Automotive sectors a good
example we're stressing today where you
need the state to be active a partner to
draw in the kind of private investment
that we're seeing in the US through
things like the inflation reduction act
but we haven't had a response here to
that in the UK you know the fact that
the UK has the lowest business
investment in the G7 with all the good
things all the strength and Innovation
that we have in the UK these are major
problems and clear is laying out the sky
scale of the challenge and his ambition
and our ambition to meet that challenge
um
it's you you feel to me I guess I think
labor very good at laying out the scale
of the challenge but what we haven't
heard so much are of are like specific
policy ideas I mean you can point to
radical Blair policies the minimum wage
for example in a speech starmer even
compares his government to the labor
government in 1945 when the National
Health Service was first set up and I
haven't really heard much on that scale
from this current labor team despite the
rhetoric is it that you don't have the
ideas or you just don't want to tell us
right now what they are
no I think our job is to is to
articulate those and get them across so
what I'm talking about specifically here
I would say look at our pledge to reform
business rates of fundamental change in
the business rate system to change the
apprenticeship Levy to let firms spend
up to half of their apprenticeship Levy
funds on other forms of training I would
look at our changes our promise changes
to the planning system to have an
industrial strategy to begin with to put
in significant public investment through
our green Prosperity fund to leverage in
the kind of private investment we need
to see and to make brexit work so if
your specific policies on rejoining the
Horizon Science Program on agreeing a
Veterinary agreement with the EU on
having the mutual recognition of
professional qualifications I'd say
these are all detailed things now what
we saw in those local elections was
clearly the conservative party rejected
and people choosing labor over the
conservatives but we know we've got more
to do none of us are complacent we've
got to get that message across of the
scale of our ambition of the hope we
want to deliver back to the country and
why these specific policies that we've
got deserve a hearing and that they are
the answers to the problems so look we
know we've got more to do but I don't
accept the case that we're not putting
forward specific policies because I
actually think compared to many
oppositions a year 18 months before a
general election we've got far more on
the table than most political parties
usually have at this stage I'm not
saying that you're not put putting
forward specific policies I'm just
talking about the scale of it when you
look at the rhetoric from kirstarma it's
going to be these Clause foreign
steroids we're going to talk talking
about the 1945 labor win you know
they're talking about policies like the
NHS like the minimum wage you know you
mentioned the inflation reduction Act of
the US that's 369 billion dollars worth
of policy and one of the policies you
mentioned is allowing firms to spend
half the apprenticeship levy on other
things I'm just talking about the scale
of what you're putting forward
well I actually think the aggregate
scale of what we're putting forward a
very different approach to the economy a
very different approach to Public
Services is worthy of that and actually
many times you mentioned those previous
governments people at the times would
have said this isn't ambitious enough
this isn't significant enough it's only
in retrospect you really get the sense
of scale on that but just to look at
what we're putting forward in my area
we're in business and Industrial
strategy this is a very significant
change it's real public money it's not
trying to match by the way the scale of
inflation production because I don't
think we can do that as a nation of our
skies and scale but it is a very
different approach to what we see at the
minute which is a government that has
some quite a eye-catching industrial
targets but no way to deliver that we're
promising the money that would go into
bringing that private investment the
changes to things like planning and the
regulation of the National Grid that
would facilitate that changes to the
skills system to business taxation you
add that up and that is a compelling and
comprehensive package it's not the full
picture yet of course there'll be more
for the manifesto but I do think it's
the kind of change that we need to turn
around living standards and of course
provide the revenue that gives us the
chance to improve public services to the
level the British people expect
we had gone shots on the program earlier
he said that the mood in the
conservative party is one of Steely
determination how do you class it
I'm not an objective Observer of the
conservative party but I think it seems
quite demoralized and has ever you know
full of internal conflicts and battles I
I look at conservative MPS and I think
to be honest many of them are looking
perhaps to a post-election period and
the succession and who might take over
but look we can't be distracted by that
we know we've got a mission to do to you
know we turn the labor party around
since 2019 and tells its perception and
the trust the public have in it we know
we've got to go further with more people
over perhaps do more on the hope and
optimism as well as the reassurance and
credibility that we've had to
re-establish so whatever the moon and
the conservative party is it doesn't
detract from the mission that we've got
in the labor party okay Jonathan
Reynolds thank you very much indeed
Jonathan Reynolds there for the labor
party
you're watching safety Ridge on Sunday
too pretty feisty interviews already
this morning and still to come on the
program this morning we have an awful
lot more guests in just a moment we'll
talk to the former business secretary
Jacob Rees Morgan be interesting to see
how his uh vision for where the
conservative party should go differs
from Grant chaps plus a bit later on the
show we'll also hear from the greater
Manchester mayor Andy Burnham and
then we're going to be joined live in
the studio by Aleister and Grace
Campbell I wonder if they'll be uh quite
as uh happy as they look in that photo
therefore there could be a little bit of
tension in the father-daughter
relationships be interesting to see how
that goes we'll also get some immediate
reaction from our political
correspondent there's Bates who is here
with us this morning good to have you on
the show Liz thanks good to be here
anything that stood out for you already
on the program or uh I enjoyed the
moment that uh Grant chaps said that the
conservative party had a general mood of
Steely uh determination because from a
kind of objective outside his
perspective and I don't know how you
feel about this it feels to me a bit
more like a kind of collective delusion
and perhaps in certain circles a bit of
uh
um maybe a bit of sadness you were at
the event yesterday right one of these
things like that uh the mood there
yesterday uh was I mean there was
certainly a lot of conservative members
some of them counselors they were angry
at the level of losses that had been
inflicted on the party at the local
elections not happy with the Rishi soon
like in fact a woman in the audience at
one point stood up and shouted Rishi
sunak out now these are not conservative
party audiences that don't tend to to
um Heckle during conferences so that was
quite a moment there was a real uh
feeling I think of wanting to bring back
Boris Johnson there was an insistence
from Jacob Reese Mark who was there that
it was not about that but everyone on
the floor I think disagreed okay we'll
have to put that to check every smoke in
just a few moments uh definitely we'll
have more from Liz later on from 9 30 as
well so definitely uh staying around for
that thank you for being here Liz thanks
now after the delay of the coronation
The Fallout from the pre-disastrous
local election results are really
starting to be felt in the conservative
party we've heard of course from people
like pretty Patel and Gene Doris who've
been withering uh in their criticism of
the current leadership in the last few
days and the decision to pull back from
plans to scrap all EU laws has also
further angered some on the right and in
that wing of the party they don't come
more prominent than Jacob priest smog
the former business secretary who joins
us now thank you so much for being on
the program
um it was we should see next fast real
test at The Ballot Box at the local
elections and we heard from Grant chaps
who said that the mood in the party is
one of Steely determination do you think
that they really those around Rishi
sunoco's allies really grasped the scale
of the challenge
well it's obviously difficult when a
party's been in office for 13 years but
Rishi sunak has been getting on with
business local election results are
often bad for incumbent governments they
were bad for Tony Blair and he then went
on to win majorities they were terrible
for Margaret Thatcher who then went on
to win very big majorities so I wouldn't
read too much into local elections
I think it's fair not to read too much
into local elections but are you
seriously saying that Russia's unite
could be like Margaret Thatcher on his
way to win a big majority of the next
election
come on
well we'll have we'll have to wait and
see I think politicians we all love
looking at elections and opinion polls
and forecasting what's going to happen
and all these sorts of things
but they are in some ways a distraction
from policy and what I think is
interesting and what yesterday was about
and what the netcon conference tomorrow
is about is developing conservative
thinking and policy what should we be
doing that will make people's lives
better and that's where the retained EU
law bill was so important not as a totem
of your skepticism but how do we make
the economy better for consumers by
cutting prices through supply side
reforms by getting rid of regulations
that make things more expensive for
people and failing to do that has been a
great mistake of the business and trade
Department
interesting because of course this was
your bill when you were a business
secretary meant to see thousands of EU
laws scrapped by the end of the year at
the same time the institute for
government said that policy reality has
finally prevailed over political
rhetoric and the bill was a poison brief
from her gung-ho predecessors most
notably Jacob Reese mock
oh
sorry you cut off briefly at the end of
the quotation but the institute for
government is
effectively the junior Ganymede
equivalent for civil servants the junior
Ganymede was the club the Jeeves
belonged to as I'm sure your viewers all
know
um so I would only expect them to come
out and give the line of the Civil
Service we've been very idle about this
need to have worked harder but what
we've got to understand is the point of
getting rid of Return To You law it's
not about
Whimsical you're a skepticism it's about
making the economy better whilst we're
in an inflationary period one of the
ways to bring down prices is by
tightening monetary policy in the
government the bank of England's doing
that and that's difficult for people the
other thing you can do that brings
prices down is free up the economy from
over regulation and this is product
regulations this is the reach
regulations
this is making it easier for people to
trade and do business and that's such a
missed opportunity particularly in
environment it's the so-called supply
side reforms that we have long needed
so you're really saying you mentioned
Jeeves there are you really saying that
it's just civil servants who are
effectively blocking this and that
Russia senior can be better knock about
that is that what you're really saying
well Grant traps was confident whilst um
he was business secretary that it could
be done I was confident that it could be
done and it seems to me there's been a
considerable lot of impetus in the last
three months partly possibly because of
the reorganization of the department
I want to talk to you about taxes as
well because this is something that came
up an awful lot yesterday and how
concerned are you about the current rate
of tax because people around me she seem
like are saying look at the minute we've
got to try and get inflation down and
actually that's the best tax cut that
anyone can have
well oddly I don't think I particularly
disagree with Rishi sunak on tax and
spend but I would be perhaps more
hawkish on spending I think the state is
spending too much we're up at 47 of GDP
we can't afford that level that's why
we've got the highest level of tax in 70
years I'm not in favor of unfunded tax
cards but I am in favor of reducing the
size of the state making sure the money
the state spends is better spend and
they're lying for tax cuts that way and
I think that's a matter of priority the
state is doing too much so where do you
think the spending Huts should fall
where should they fall well you've
certainly got to look at the Civil
Service that when I was um in cabinet
office we had a plan to reduce the civil
service by 91
000. I think we should cut things like
hs2 which are a terrible white elephant
you you begin to find there are many
billions to be saved once you save the
billions uh you are able to give people
their own money back that's the thing to
remember there's no such thing as
government money it's all taxpayers
money and the government should only
take from taxpayers the minimum that is
necessary to provide the services that
are required and do you think Richardson
gets that
but I doubt he would disagree
particularly with that um view of
conservative values
now you receive
us prime minister
there's no good being holier than now if
you end up behaving like a
bourgeoisier I'm no historian right I
have no idea what a border is so what
border what do they behave like
oh well actually there's a very
interesting revisionist biography of
Pope Alexander VI which indicates that
he wasn't as bad as history has thought
in so perhaps the borders aren't as bad
as all that
um what I was saying was the Prime
Minister gave a very clear promise just
to come in if I may if I may what what
do they do what were they known for
oh those are the borders nepotism and
all sorts of carry-on going on there's a
very good kind of carry on what kind of
carry-on
I I I I suggest you read the relevant
books
genuinely
you've talked about it
as I say there's a revisionist biography
on PayPal Alexander you might want to
read that too but the point I was making
was that you can't put out a campaign
video with the shredder working full
speed about uh overheat getting rid of
EU laws and then break that promise
that's the key that promises that are
given by politicians ought to be stuck
to particularly when they're that clear
and specific
reference to
the board they do everyone knows about
the borders everyone knows about the
borders but as I say people have
different views why won't you tell us
what they did then if everyone knows
about them
history lecture
if I'm happy with the reference but if
people want history lecturers I'll give
them on GB news 3 8 and 9 o'clock every
Monday to Thursday
okay you've got your reference in there
tell us what the said what did
they do
educate me the the the borders paper
Alexander VI was a Spaniard who became
paper at the end of the uh 15th century
um he'd been in the curia for for many
years he was very unpopular with a lot
of the Italians who didn't want to have
a Spanish Pope
um and his successor but one
um indicated that he had done all sorts
of things he probably hadn't done
including having children which for Pope
is unusual
um he was certainly nepotistic he
certainly appointed
his nephews to important posts within
the curia and he may have been poisoned
at the end of his life it's not entirely
clear there's a sort of brief Canter
through the history of the borders which
I must confess I wasn't expecting to be
talking about this morning
so corrupt effectively is that what
you're really referencing to Rishi
Scenic no I think you're delving into
this far too much now I didn't think um
he was corrupt but I think he broke a
promise
that was the point
was it a mistake to get rid of Boris
Johnson in your view
I mean of course it was I've said that a
million times but it would be an even
bigger mistake now to get rid of Rishi
sunak the conception cannot keep on
changing leaders we we must back the
leader we have got
so no sense let me be clear about that
and I said this at the conference
yesterday the CDO conference
um that the Tory party would be toast if
we changed leader again and therefore we
need to support the leader we've got but
but that doesn't mean we agree with him
on every policy and have a debate about
policy is important and I hope
interesting for conservative members in
the country at Large
and now just finally you of course used
to be the brexit opportunities Minister
now we've got someone on later you've
probably heard of him as a Campbell you
know he's no fan of brexit and I'm sure
he's going to be very vocal in giving us
all of the reasons why brexit has been a
big disaster so help me out what would
you come back to him on to say these
have been the benefits of leaving the
European Union
okay well we saved 191 billion pounds
191 billion pounds by not being in the
EU for its covered Recovery Fund that
would have been our share of the eu's
Recovery Fund 191 billion that's one
thing
um what else we've got a free trade deal
uh with Australia which will be much
better than the forecasts uh predict we
were able to show Global Leadership uh
over Ukraine and Putin would probably
have invaded Ukraine successfully if the
UK had been bound in by the requirement
of sincere cooperation and had had to
follow a franco-german line in dealing
with Russia which is what we did in
2014. so those are three huge benefits
cash benefit to British for British
taxpayers so you genuinely believe that
Putin would have successfully invaded
Ukraine if the UK had been part of the
EU
I think the leadership trained by Boris
Johnson which he could only do because
he was not bound by sincere cooperation
ensured that a coalition was set up that
made it impossible for Putin to succeed
and I think if that hadn't been the case
we'd been bound by this concept of
sincere Corporation we'd have had the
Mucky compromise that would um delivered
in 2014 when Russia invaded the Crimea I
think it's really important but above
all of this we've got democracy so we
can decide how we're governed rather
than having to do what we're told by
Aleister Campbell's mates
I'll put that to him thank you very much
uh indeed Jake every Smog on the program
today great pleasure thank you
no Regional Mayors have become an
established and increasingly prominent
part of our politics think Andy Street
in the West Midland City Khan in London
and in greater Manchester we have Andy
Burnham now he's now been in the job six
years he recently signed a new
Devolution deal with Westminster that
expands his powers and he joins us now
thanks very much being on the program uh
Mr Burnham so we just mentioned there
the Devolution deal seen as a bit of a
Trailblazer what are you going to do
with the new powers
yes it's quite exciting actually Sophie
we've got the ability now to have more
control over post 16 technical education
and we've long called for that because I
believe it's an issue that the country
has neglected a new education in England
that's been dominated by the university
route under all parties to be honest so
we have the chance now to fix it so
instead of just there being one clear
route for young people towards
University which starts with English
Baccalaureate and goes to a levels and
then ucas and ends obviously with a
degree we want to create an equivalent
uh route for young people who want a
technical qualification or a good job in
the greater Manchester economy so we're
going to bring in the the Manchester
Baccalaureate uh that will lead towards
T levels and other technical
qualifications we then have gmax which
is our equivalence of ucas to try and
help people find opportunities in the
greater National economy and then it
takes people to a good apprenticeship a
degree apprenticeship or an other
another higher qualification so it's
really exciting to be honest it's just
the reform that greater Manchester needs
right now we're a really fast growing
successful vibrant modern economy you
can see that in the skyline of our city
center but there's a risk we won't bring
through the talented young people that
we need and this fixes it
you're obviously pretty excited by some
of these opportunities do you think we
should give the government some credit
for being serious about devolving Powers
outside of Westminster
yes and I do you know I very much take a
place first rather than party first
approach in my role as mayor of Greater
Manchester
um and I I try to call it as it is I'm
conscious that when I was elected in
2017 and then again in 2021 people of
all political Persuasions lent me their
support so it's important that I am a
voice that that represents all of that
opinion and puts our place first and the
government does deserve credit for
delivering a Devolution agreement that
takes greater Manchester to the next
level so it's not just more power over
technical education we're gonna going to
be able to do something about housing
standards particularly in the private
rented sector by bringing in a greater
Manchester good landlord that Charter
also people know we've been on with a
major reform of public transport next
month I will put out a London style
integrated Fair structure that will make
public transport cheaper in Greater
Manchester and in time we can bring the
trains into to into that integrated
system it was a bit of a victory for the
Mayors I have to say last week when the
transport secretary agreed to our
request to bring transparent Express
under under public control that gives us
a real opportunity now to reshape the
railways in the north and make them work
much better for the public
there's going to be more scrutiny two of
your role right including from
Committees of local MPS and Sky News
recently did a story about a policing
crime commissioner who triggered two
police investigations into his political
opponents do you think there is a risk
that as we give more power to local
bodies whether that's policing crime
Commissioners whether that's Mayors and
partly of course because of the frankly
the decimation of local press that there
is a risk about scrutiny and holding
people to account properly
yes yes I do and I um I worry about it
because you know Devolution in England
is working it really is working you know
just just look at the positive energy
that's flowing around greater Manchester
right now you know we are beginning to
see the rebalancing of the UK economy
and it's and it's a great thing and
obviously when you have power
this level that we have you can make
change from the bottom up with people
and I think I was touching on these
themes yesterday it's really working and
I would hate to see it derail
buy some Corrupt Practices of the kind
that you're that you're that you're
mentioning so when I was in the
discussions with the government and they
were saying that they wanted uh Stronger
accountability uh structures and
arrangements and actually conservative
MPS and greater Manchester were saying
the same thing that they were unhappy
with power being given without you know
the checks and balances and I agreed
with them to us and I said to the
government look you go as far as you
like that's the deal if we get more
power I don't mind at all you know being
called before any parliamentary
committee and in fact what I've
suggested is that the government sets up
a greater Manchester Grand Committee in
Parliament similar to the Scottish brand
committee and the Welsh Grand committee
so there can be full scrutiny of what
we're of what we're doing so you were
right to raise that issue but we don't
we don't fear it at all
now I just want to talk to you a bit
about National politics if I may because
obviously labor did rather well at the
local elections it seems pretty clear
that right now if the polls and if the
local elections were projected onto the
House of Commons it would be Kirsten
number 10. but not necessarily with a
majority
take on this whole round about the
whether Kirsten should rule in or out a
coalition with the lib Dems what do you
think
well I don't think he needs to at this
point in time he needs to set out his
his own store uh and he's doing that and
he did that yesterday I read the speech
I don't think the headlines
um did Justice to it it was quite a
considered uh Speech and I think
increasingly now he's got that
opportunity to lay out a program that
will deliver a a good working majority
for him under labor labor government the
local elections told us very clearly
that the public is ready for change uh
and I think he also said it's not yet
you know in the position where it's
completely
um clear that it's you know it's it's a
majority labor government but I think we
will get there and that's the next phase
of the project that I think here in the
shadow cabinet are building and I hope
they can draw on some of the things that
we're doing you know I think it would be
a mistake to suggest this will be like
1997 all over again you know we need to
come up with a program that's right for
the times that we're in I was really
proud obviously to be in that government
and all the great things that we did but
looking back you know I would say we did
neglect some issues so we did Focus too
much on the University route as I was
saying before and we should have done
much more on technical education when it
comes to the NHS it shouldn't always
just be about targets and recruiting
more doctors and nurses we should have
fixed social care when we were in when
we were in power and I'd like to see a
radical agenda kind of developed around
around that as well or if you take
housing promoting home ownership is an
important thing but if you do that on
its own you'll still have a housing
prices and actually you need a housing
policy that's about building more uh
modern Council homes social homes and
also as I said before getting serious
about housing standards in private
rented rented sector and much stronger
regulation there so develop develop an
agenda that's right for now and labor
will get that majority government and so
it's it's exciting times for the party
if they fall short at the majority then
one of the things the lib Dems could be
demanding is proportion representation a
change the voting system do you think
that should be a red line for labor or
do you think it's something that perhaps
perhaps labor should also embrace no I
do I I I've come around to it I'll be
honest I I wasn't always in this
position but when you step outside of
Westminster you look at things afresh
and you know I I've looked at how our
doesn't really flow properly throughout
this this country the first past the
post system I think has more power to
the establishment than it does to
um to MPS actually but beyond that to
people and I think PR would put the
people much more in control every every
vote would matter and so I've you know
I've come around I've got the Zeal of
the convert I I personally believe if
you're going to really make this country
work properly for all people in all
places It's a combination of
proportional representation for the
commons
Senate of the Nations and regions to
replace the unelected Lords because how
can it be right in this day and age that
you know all places aren't represented
equally in our national Parliament and
then thirdly I would have maximum
Devolution of power to the uh to the to
the regional or city region level like
like we've got in Greater Manchester
that that would make the country work
much better make it much fairer for
everybody and I would like to see uh
that agenda not be not be taken off the
table let's say okay thanks very much
pretty clear always good to talk to you
thanks thank you thank you very much
now there are a few political names that
stare as many strong feelings should we
say as Alice Alistair Campbell someone
who's not shy in expressing his own well
the former New labor spinner has become
a hit podcaster he also has a new book
out and his daughter Grace has built her
own very successful career as a writer
and comedian she's also known for her
defensive feminism and they both join us
now thank you very much for being with
us I have to say I'm quite excited about
having you both on the program together
um thank you for coming in thank you for
having us no good to see you
um so you've got a new book out you say
that politics is broken why
I think the big breaker of it has been
some of the issues you've just been
discussing Andy there I think populism
polarization and the fact that we're now
thanks to brexit and Boris Johnson in a
post-truth world similar to Trump
Trump's America
um and added to which I I think that the
a lot of people of Grace's generation
are just sort of looking at politics and
thinking I think they really really care
about the world really care about trying
to make change in the world but they're
looking at politics and how they see it
done and thinking this just doesn't has
very little to do with me yeah do you
think that's right though I mean I do
yeah increasingly so especially at the
moment the the Tories feel so far
removed from like most people I know and
lots of people of My Generation
Um and then also I think like culturally
they just feel really far removed from
us but I think I mean we've been talking
about this for such a long time actually
because since I started doing
activism I guess
um I I've realized how many young people
and this is when I was actually young I
feel like I I can't how old are you now
I just turned 29. that's definitely
still young I know my book well anything
under 30 yeah but then young people are
like so much more impressive you know
like late teens early people in their
early 20s at the moment are just doing
such unbelievable things but I remember
thinking that when I started doing all
of that I was like well there are all of
these young people who are unbelievably
impressive and inspiring but wouldn't
consider a career in politics and that's
really depressing it is quite depressing
isn't it don't you think do you think
that actually politics is turning off
and I'm not even making this party
political but just generally just
turning off young people from politics
from running to bmps well I think
there's lots of I actually think that
the way that the media covers Politics
as well is a problem I think people look
at it and then social media as well you
know women young women and women of
color in particular the abuse that they
see other women getting it puts them off
but Grace is right I mean you know I was
really pleased to hear I saw you to you
Jonathan Reynolds I really hope labor
are going to fight to lower the voting
age I think that's really important I I
see the reason I've written the book the
title but what can I do the title comes
from the fact that that's what young
people say to me the whole time but what
can we do because this isn't this isn't
the politics that we sort of feel we
need and again I thought Andy was
interesting there that you know the
change that the politics has it's got to
be much more than a change of government
we've got to change the way that we do
politics and we've got to understand
young people have got so much energy
they have got so much commitment not all
of them I remember I say in the book
that Grayson when Grace was like in her
teens and I said look we should lower
the voting age and I remember Grace
saying dad you've met some of my friends
they know nothing about me and I will
say yeah but 40s 50s 60s 70 year olds we
need we need we just need massive
political education in this country you
know what was the most Google thing the
day after the referendum what is the EU
I mean that's terrifying so I think that
Grace's generation is the answer to it
to a lot of these problems and and uh
you know we've got to have such big
change and it's but I think to in order
to get a lot of those people to want to
go into politics politics has to change
and the way that we treat politicians
has to change and I think that that you
know I think about this a lot I mean
less and less so but I used to get told
a lot that I should go into politics I
think now my my comedy is quite like the
opposite of what politicians are allowed
so there'll be a few things that are
quite problematic now yeah but I used to
get that a lot and it I know I never
ever ever was attracted to it because of
the abuse that you get and I I saw that
firsthand like my entire childhood and
then also the way that a lot of the time
you aren't actually allowed to say what
you think and how you feel and you have
to sort of you know you're really scared
of what other people and like what your
party might say to you and then the
abuse that women get online women of
color I mean it's just horrific like why
would you want to do that well because
you can change the world yeah but you
can change the world in other ways you
can I think that's the thing that people
see now now is that actually sometimes
you can have more power shouting from
the outside which maybe you know well
look at you look at you having a
Resurgence in your career now no you're
shouting from the outside yeah shouting
from the outside he's always been
shouting wherever he is however the
thing is for example about Gretch
tunberg
um Gretch tunberg is a great example of
somebody who an individual who just
started a protest and has made a
difference and it's true she's made a
difference but ultimately if you're
really really really going to make
change you've got to get in and Lead
governments that is where the big change
is do you think kissed armor is ready to
make big changes because in the
interview with John from Reynolds I
guess what I was trying to say is look
there's a lot of rhetoric right now
coming out of the labor party saying we
can be on Clause 4 on steroids they're
referencing 1945. where's the evidence
of a radical political policy I thought
I was really I watched your interview in
the green room and I thought it was a
really interesting interview because I
could see where you were coming from and
I could also see where he was coming
from what I really like about what care
has done is he's so methodical people
say he's dull and he's boring he's is
methodical and I think we need a bit of
that so he's gone stage one
decontaminate labor brand post the
Corbin period stage two show that the
Tories are absolutely useless and unfit
to govern stage three here's the big
positive agenda and I think what's going
to happen with these missions that
they've got and now this rhetoric as you
say is they they're Now setting
themselves that Target for those big
policy ideas to come they've now got to
happen and I kind of agree with both you
and Jonathan I think there is a lot
there that they're they're projecting
but actually for the public there's very
little sense of how that's going to
change affect and change their lives and
I think that's the next stage for labor
so I was more hopeful after yesterday
actually that labor really does
understand the scale of the challenge
and they can never again Jonathan made
this point no matter how bad the
government is you can never rely on that
you've got to focus on your own agenda
your own strategy and Get It Over The
Line what do you make a cursed armor
well I mean actually I think he's doing
a good job now I mean I am so sick of
the Tory government that we just need to
to get labor and power and I have you
know there are things that care does
that I guess that can always on people
of my generation but I just keep saying
like I know so well from growing up with
him and this has been his rhetoric my
entire life there is nothing you can do
when you're not in power so what was it
like growing up with Alistair Campbell's
your dad
yeah
which territory for comedy
um it was very interesting never a dull
moment with him I would say
um but it was quite it was also at times
quite stressful I'm very protective of
him you know like I I don't like people
saying bad things about him I I feel
sometimes I have to be with him in case
he gets into an argument so you're a bit
like his bodyguard
oh that would have been really bad but
thankfully I was there anything about he
doesn't like fighting in front of me
because he's such a nice guy you just do
it away from Grace said instead right do
it he used to take me places when I was
a kid so because then he he felt it
would calm him down if I was there he'd
be less likely to get into a blow up
what's the biggest thing you two
disagree about
um actually you know what I feel he has
I really feel he's listening so much on
like you know women's stuff and I think
you know I do credit myself to a lot of
him now being really aware of things
that he just wasn't anything in
particular that you give an example well
I just like the the treatment of women
and like the things that women go
through that I guess like a lot of men
need to listen to more I need to not
just like pretend they're listening
actually engage in and understand like
what it is like to be a woman in this
Society I use specific example I
actually write about in the book is the
period poverty campaign I'd never really
thought about that and it was only when
Grace came along with her friend
Scarlett Curtis and sort of sat badan
said that this is really really really
bad and why is nobody talking about this
and then the next thing they're running
a campaign and they've got a change in
the law but also even on a sort of like
taboo thing he didn't even like really
like talking about periods then and then
I've confronted a lot of that of like
normalizing some of the conversations
that should just not be a shameful thing
for women
like that we are last five ten years
stuff like periods we can talk about on
TV which I just can't really imagine
that happening so much when I was
growing up or young women well I can
remember the argument going on in in
which budget it was but there's a budget
about whether there was a discussion
about whether we can say tampon tax
it's ridiculous you actually can't
um now I have to admit right I did an
event recently with your dad and I was
quite surprised by the amount of
attention that he got he was mobbed
there was one woman who came up to you
with a sex Squad badge I mean how and
then he wore it for a week how do you
keep his ego in check yeah
um quite easily yeah yeah I mean I guess
you get quite a lot of attention the
other way as well right I think me and
my mum humble him quite a lot actually
but I think it's a good thing because he
can get a bit you know big for his boots
sometimes so I think you need to you
were shocked though weren't you I was
but then I have got I'll be honest on
social media there's plenty of people
the other way as well oh yeah yeah but
they're the ones who go on social media
but the ones who come to your face tend
to be very very nice that's why it's
quite nice to be learned about yeah just
don't go on Twitter just go I don't
really bother about Twitter I tweet too
much and I but I don't look at the
comments but we did a video when I was
on tour in Leicester and we went up to
people in the street saying have you
ever heard of Grace Campbell nobody knew
who I was nobody knew who you were two
people
earlier on the program and I asked him
about the benefits of brexit to put to
you right he talked about the not having
to be part of the 199 billion pound
covered Recovery Fund he talked about
the retail do with Australia he talked
about the Global Leadership we showed in
Ukraine and he said or above all it's
about democracy so that we don't have to
be told what to do by Alison Campbell
and his Mates is that what you said yeah
well I'd say on the on on Ukraine uh I I
would definitely say that the UK has
done a good job in relation to Ukraine
but that has nothing to do with us being
outside the European Union the
Australian trade deal and all the other
trade deals done they've done they're
either cut and pays for what we had with
the EU or they're adding a minuscule
amount in the long term to our trade
which is none which has meanwhile been
absolutely battered Jacob Reese Smoke's
dad is a big part of the book because he
wrote Jacob Blue Smoke's dad William
wrote a book back in 1997 called the
sovereign individual and that is what
brexit is about for the Jacob Reese mock
types it's and it's sought in your
interview it's about getting rid of
Taxation getting rid of Regulation and
actually getting rid of democratic
control so I actually think if that's
the best he can do for the benefits
given he had the job Secretary of State
for brexit opportunities it underlines
to me the fact that brexit is going very
very badly wrong what about not being
told what to say by us Campbell and his
mates
well I don't think I'd tell anybody what
to do he's he's an elected politician
the government has the power and the
argument I got into on news night the
other night was about this whole
question of sovereignty the whole thing
about sovereignty was a myth because the
sovereignty always lay in the UK
Parliament to pull some of that
sovereignty with other nations and since
we've stopped that I mean you you that's
cheered me up that because he Jacob
Reese Morgan spends his whole life
thinking about this to me has got not a
single benefit of brexit that he's put
forward well I'm sure that viewers will
draw whatever conclusions they like from
Jacob Reese smorg and as a Campbell
thank you both but what can I do thank
you very much indeed for being on the
program today and really good to have
you on as well thank you thank you
Alistair and Grace Campbell there well
that is it this week so if you're done
Sunday in a moment after the break we
will run through today's interviews
looking at what we learned with our
political correspondent Liz Bates thanks
for joining us this Sunday
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
again
[Music]
hello welcome back this is Sophie Ridge
on Sunday the take a chance to look back
at some of our interviews on the program
this morning try and work out what we
learned it really feels to me like this
weekend is where we've really start to
feel the impact of those local election
results it was a bit delayed because of
the coronation but now the impact in the
conservative party and the different
factions of the conservative party are
really coming to the to the fore we had
Grant chaps on the program this morning
for the government and he was trying to
say that actually look the party's full
of Steely determination there's no issue
to see here but we've got these two
conferences uh one yesterday uh one
tomorrow and it really does feel like
the kind of Warring Wings the
conservative party are starting to be
felt managed decline as how pretty Patel
put it and as a result we're seeing lots
of ideas for things that British Cenac
needs to do differently let's have a
quick listen first we'll get our
thoughts from applicable correspondent
Liz Bates in a moment but first let's
just have a little listen to Grant chaps
I asked him simply describe the moon to
the concepter party
I think that uh the mood is one of
Steely determination well I think we
think that we
um know that there's a job to do that we
are on the side of the British people
and you know whether that is getting
inflation halved or growing the economy
uh or reducing debt dealing with the NHS
waiting list okay and the rest of it
okay stopping the boats we're the ones
who are on the side of the public
uh grunt shops there uh well let's talk
to Liz Bates uh now shall we now Liz you
were at on these conferences yesterday
right so you heard from all of these uh
figures yesterday would you sum up the
mood as steel determination it certainly
wasn't at the conference that I was at
the conference that I was at uh was uh
largely disillusioned conservative party
members and some of those MPS as well
that were very big during the Boris
Johnson years so Jacob reesemark Nadine
dory's pretty Patel they are very much
in the Wilderness at the moment so of
course they're not particularly happy
with the direction of travel and look it
it's not at the level of full-on Revolt
Jacob Reese mug was at that conference
he was urging people to get behind but
she's doing it but what I think it shows
is the honeymoon period for the prime
minister is over the factions in the
conservative party still exist and there
is trouble brewing and I think the
message from that conference was we're
keeping an eye on you we still have a
level of power to keep you in line if we
think you're going off in the wrong
direction and we have the party
membership behind us I guess my kind of
big thought after the local elections
right is where does Russia's unite go
um you heard Grand champ said that
they're saying look it wasn't a
referendum on Richardson it was
basically people expressing their
frustration with the last year of
conservative party chaos as in Liz truss
and everything else rather than just
Rishi sunac
but the message from that seems to be
that they're not going to change
direction they're going to focus on
delivery they're going to focus on the
aims that he's already set out do you
think that's going to be enough to
appease those on the right of the
concept apart I mean I think the way
that you've set it out there perfectly
represents the challenge that Rishi
sunak faces because he is at the end of
almost 13 well we don't know if he's at
the end of this but it's starting to
feel like the end of 13 years of
conservative government he has to Face
the Nation sell himself show that there
is a future for the conservative party
that is new and different under him at
the same time he has to appease his
party but also take on the labor party
which is showing a credible alternative
these are the different challenges that
he faces and I think what you can see
from what Grant chaps are saying this
morning is the way that they're going to
manage that is they are going to take a
strategy plow ahead with it it's about
delivery it's about
competence the problem for issue like is
I think he was
doing well certainly in Westminster and
there was a feeling among his party that
he was showing that the conservative
party was now the party of competence
and that would go down well with the
election well we see from the local
elections that it hasn't and they
haven't changed course and that's why
these different factions are starting to
get a bit irritated it felt to me like
it was a bit of a beauty pageant for the
next leader is that fair is it are we
starting to see that look I mean I know
we haven't even got an election called
yet so that feels a long way off but it
felt a little bit like that right I I
think we are getting into that territory
I mean the interesting thing about the
conservative party is I think over the
certainly over the past few years it's
changed in terms of its approach to
leadership it used to be a party that
would in difficult times unite because
they just simply do not want to lose
power they want to keep winning general
elections well this is a a party that
has become increasingly mutinous and
that's what was certainly on my mind
yesterday at that conference was that
they are much more willing now to remove
their leaders we've seen it happen and
we all we know as well that Boris
Johnson I mean Nadine I spoke to Nadine
Doris yesterday she was insisting that
Boris Johnson is really enjoying his
time off and doesn't want to come back
we know that Boris Johnson will always
wait in the wings to cause trouble
um but I think there's many other
characters now that are thinking about
the next leader that's a real problem
for issue soon like it feels like end of
days territory oh yeah really
interesting and thanks to the analysis
uh Liz the other thing that I was Keen
to talk to Grant chaps about on the
program was strikes because it does feel
look if he's pitching himself as the
deal maker if he's pitching himself as a
person who can sort out some of the
issues facing the country than public
sector strikes has got to be right up
there on his priority list and of course
the leader of the nursing Union uh the
Aussie and Pat Cullen has said that the
next round of pay rise negotiations
would have to start in double digit
had to say
it's a very curious story indeed um
because Pat Callum just recently was
encouraging her members to uh settle for
the pay rise that was put on the table
uh that would see 5000 pounds go into
the pockets of this year of uh our
hard-working nurses I thought this was a
great settlement I thought it's terrific
that it had been uh reached it's frankly
rather confusing uh now that having
encouraged her members to accept that
deal she seems to now be coming back and
saying the opposite so absolutely no to
double-digit terrorize them well as I
say you've got to balance that with the
rest of the public purse and there's a
very generous offer now on the table
five five grand uh you know this year
would be coming to nurses
um and uh I think that that would be a
great way to get this thing settled
I mean I guess away from the noise this
is one of the most important stories
this weekend right and Pat Collins
saying look we want a double-digit pay
rise for nurses
um yes and this is something that seems
like it's going to go on and on both
sides digging in
um it it also shows the again the
problems that Mishi sunak is facing this
is the reality these are the things that
voters really care about at the strikes
across the board but also the NHS not
functioning public properly and then
when you actually look at the party
they're arguing about things like taking
a retained EU law off the British
statute so this is the conservative
party need interface reality needing to
sort out these problems and not being
able to and then also having lots of
internal arguments as well and I think
that's why it feels like the party's in
a really difficult place at the moment
um let's talk a bit about Labor shall we
because obviously you could see labor
being pretty happy with those local
election results but I guess what they
also underlined was just how big a swing
labor need in order to get a majority
that is a tall order isn't it it sure is
and I think what I really liked actually
about your last interview with Alistair
Campbell was the way that he set out the
progress that he thought the labor party
needed to make now he said that they
needed to what that they had that
kirstan had detoxified the party showed
that the conservatives were not fit to
govern and then it was now creating a
Grand Vision well I would argue with him
on some of those points I think I think
here starmer has detoxified the brand
um it's the conservatives that have
shown themselves uh that they are in a
in a tricky spot when it comes to
governing I don't think labor have
really done that and when it comes to
the Grand Vision I think you set this up
perfectly with Johnny Reynolds there's a
long list of policies Johnny Reynolds
could rattle them off very easily
something to do with business rates what
is the Grand Vision what does a Kia
start my country look like and I think
voters still don't know that and I think
that is why we saw the local elections
big swings but will they win a majority
will they be able to govern long term I
think we still have the answers to that
yeah the big Vision thing I do think is
is an important one and I genuinely
can't work out if it's because they just
want to save it until closer to the
election for strategy reasons or because
there actually isn't one I actually
don't know to be completely honest
um who knows um let's have a quick
listen to uh Johnny Reynolds uh shall we
I was talking to him about kiss Thomas
vision for Clause 4 on steroids under
his leadership let's listen well I think
there are Arguments for expanding the
franchise it's not an area I directly
deal with in the shadow cabinet so I'm
not going to give a definitive answer on
that but I think we should always be
seeking to involve as many people as
possible in our democracy that's what
strengthens Democratic politics that's
what we need to see encouraged and I
think we haven't seen enough of that in
recent times so it's something we will
we will look at but some of the reports
as I've got to stress they're not the
fair final plans for the labor Manifesto
this is about the process by which we
achieve that Manifesto
I made a mistake there I thought that
was about Clause 4 and steroids I got
the wrong bit of to the Jennifer
Reynolds that was him talking about the
voting system let's listen now to when
he was talking about chloroform steroids
it's not just turning around an economy
that hasn't functioned very well for 13
years it's the complete reform and
delivery on public services in a way
where they need the scale of that I
don't think has ever been greater and
specifically for me on the economic side
of the shuttle cabinet that's bringing
the kind of modern industrial strategy
we see in other countries we see many
parts of our company Automotive sectors
a good example we're stressing today
where you need the state to be active a
partner to draw in the kind of private
investment that we're seeing in the US
through things like the inflation
reduction act but we haven't had a
response here to that in the UK you know
the fact that the UK has the lowest
business investment in the G7 with all
the good things all the strength and
Innovation that we have in the UK these
are major problems and clear is laying
out the scale of the challenge and his
ambition and our ambition to meet that
challenge
got there on the end I need another
coffee obviously early start on Sunday I
need to keep my caffeine levels uh fully
as stocked up and should we chat about
the voting system stuff I thought that
was quite interesting and because in a
way he was saying like these are just
reports it's not official policy but it
was pretty clear that he backs it right
yes I mean this is one of the things
that has come out recently about the
labor party it's something potentially
that we can hang our hat on in terms of
what the labor party stands for
extending uh the franchise it could be
that that just means that there's a lot
more labor voters but to be honest we've
seen that happen on the conservative
side as well lots of boundary changes
and of course voter ID at the last local
elections so yeah it's an interesting
policy it does seem like that's
something that's going to get rolled out
and they're just talking about again
about the sort of rhetoric and the
language that Labor's using they're
talking pretty big right do you get any
sense that there's going to be some
bumper policy announcements anytime soon
or I agree with you I I think where the
labor party is at and Kia starma is hard
working and methodical and he saw where
the labor party was at and where it
needed to be and what they did was they
ditched all of that ideology
that came with Jeremy corbyn he's moved
the party into the center ground because
he knows that that is where uh political
parties
um win general elections but there is no
big Vision you you set out some policies
that we can very easily point to when it
comes to previous governments you know
things like the minimum wage under Tony
Blair huge house building policies under
previous uh labor governments what is
the policy that really will Define the
care style of government we don't have
that and it does feel like they're
offered to the electorate at the moment
is we will just manage things better
than the conservative party now given
what the conservative party has been
through over the last few years maybe
that is a decent offer at the moment of
the election but I think they will need
more if they want to take more of the
country that's it it's the difference
between kind of just
limbering over the line and looping over
the line almost isn't it um and I I do
sometimes wonder as well whether they're
slightly Bound by the iron grip that
they say they have on the public
finances because I guess those are the
two sort of Warring different things
that they might need to do in the labor
party I'm always good to get your
analysis uh Liz lovely had to have Liz
on the program this morning we'll have
more from her after this short break
[Music]
foreign
who raised me as a single mother
um and have worked for 30 years
unfortunately when she had a moment of
need for the Health Service
unfortunately it just wasn't there for
her she was 74 otherwise very fit and
healthy
um and upon her hospital care she had
eight assessments across her initial
passing through a e where she waited for
12 hours being before being assessed by
our first year doctor and then through
Cardiology and then as an outpatient and
not once did they consider pulmonary
embolism as a potential symptom that's a
blood clot in the vein that causes heart
failure and yet it's the third highest
heart disease killer after acute
coronary syndrome and then stroke she
had 90 percent of the symptoms
um so shortness of breath chest pain
faintness and she had a prior deep vein
thrombosis which is the other symptom
relevant and and upon early diagnosis
and treatment it has a 92 survival rate
and upon the complaint that I'd raised
to the trust
um that they they decided that upon
their own review which wasn't
particularly independent that they
wouldn't have done anything differently
so after that
um not only had I lost my mother
um but we felt let down by the internal
investigation so I started writing and
researching and looked into providing my
own independent report which I released
in conjunction with patient safety
learning a charity and and uh Joe
Jerome's charity thrombosis UK the NHS
England has actually led the world in
doing risk assessments on everybody
admitted into hospital and they've done
this because they know this is one of
the highest group of at-risk individuals
for blood clots
and they had brought the rate of death
due to blood clots associated with
hospitals down but in during the
pandemic this was suspended and the data
has not been collected so we no longer
know or have that data to see whether
people are carrying out VT risk
assessments and then implementing
um appropriate treatments to reduce an
individual's risk what we do have is a
more recent report in 2020 and it shows
it too often the risk assessment isn't
being done or the follow-up care needed
to reduce those risks isn't there's
errors or further training is needed to
safeguard those patients at risk
foreign
[Music]
hello welcome back to the take where we
take you through some analysis of this
morning's interviews so we've heard from
Grant chaps we've heard from Jonathan
Reynolds quite often though I feel with
these shows the most interesting
interviews are given by people who are
not a member of the front bench teams it
just gives them that bit more leeway to
say what they really think uh Jacob
Bruce MOG never somebody who shies away
from giving his opinion I've had quite a
lot of people on Twitter saying why have
you got him on the program well frankly
the reason is because he is influential
among one of the key wings of the
conservative party the right he's a
backbencher and he's certainly not
averse to causing a few problems for
Rishi sunac now on the show today he
said that he still thinks it was a
mistake to get rid of Boris Johnson
although he was effectively saying that
he backs Rishi United's leadership now
let's listen
I mean of course it was I've said that a
million times but it would be an even
bigger mistake now to get rid of Rishi
sunak the conservative party cannot keep
on changing leaders we we must back the
leader we have got
I'm supporting Rishi sudak let me be
clear about that and I said this at the
conference yesterday the CDO conference
um that the Tory party would be toast if
we change leader again and therefore we
need to support the leader we've got but
but that doesn't mean we agree with him
on every policy and to have a debate
about policy is important and I hope
interesting for conservative members in
the country at Large
where she um Jacob response there saying
that he is supportive of Rishi sinag do
you think that's what do you think of
that claim well I think there's a few
different elements uh to that first of
all uh can we just take a moment to
commend Jacob reesmark for sticking so
rigidly to his own brand was he sitting
in a museum it was an oil painting
behind him potentially
um this uh urging people to back Mrs
sunak I I felt like first of all
Jacob Jacob Reese smog is a realist he's
slightly under threat even in his own
constituency although he's got a pretty
decent majority of the lib Dems are
threatening him uh I think there he
knows that the damage that's been done
to the party by changing leaders and
although he is a big fan uh no question
of Boris Johnson he I think believes
that changing the lead again would be a
bad idea before the next general
election the other thing that really
came across to me and I saw him speaking
um at that conference yesterday
um
that was that that was him saying we
still hold sway within the party you may
have sidelined this Wing we still have a
voice we've got the members behind us
and it was him saying I can wield the
knife if I want to exactly I won't do it
now but I can and I can influence you
while you're in the seat as well we had
a bit of a turn for about The Borges
right
um I guess I was being a little bit
playful there by saying look just tell
me who are who are these guys explain it
but the serious point I was trying to
make is I feel that Jacob Reese Morgan
we see that with Boris Johnson as well
they drop in these references and they
know that they'll then be written up
saying The Borges are these kind of
murdering corrupt guys who ended up
getting poisoned this is the reference
he was making well if that's what you're
saying
say it on TV then you know make make the
actual accusation you're saying about
Richard Cena and he wouldn't do it would
you no I mean Jacob Reese smog uh
whatever you think of his politics is a
skillful communicator and he has been
like that for many years under many
different Prime Ministers and he
sprinkles these little references
throughout his uh uh contributions to
public life and again that is him saying
to Rishi sunak I'm here you need to take
notice of me
um I uh I have power within the party
and I can do damage to you if I want to
now in the outbreak Millers were
chatting about her day yesterday
um and Liz was revealed that she spent
six hours on the coach down to
Bournemouth didn't you um because the
rail strikes yesterday and that is
dedication isn't it on a Saturday to go
to a conference of conservative party
members what was the kind of main sort
of takeaway then after after you went
down and well I was extremely grumpy
because I spent six hours on a couch and
but my main takeaway was you know it's
one of the things that's interesting
about the conservative party is they are
very willing
to swallow all sorts of things in return
for winning general elections and the
grumblings at that conference were about
feeling that maybe Rishi Suna isn't an
election winner and there was a lot of
affection for Boris Johnson and it's not
particularly because of his policies or
his ideology is because he was at their
their prime minister that got them that
HC majority and they are still holding
on to that and many of them there want
to see him return yeah they certainly uh
do Liz thank you very much for all your
analysis lovely to have you here in the
studio today we'll have more from Liz on
the podcast as well because see as a
frigid Sunday podcast will be available
around lunchtime it features me Liz and
also show editor Scott Beasley so do
check out that one available where if
you get your podcast from
um that's it for this week thank you
very much for watching this morning we
will see you next time
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]